Good evening.
You guys make me do this every Wednesday.
And I am I'm going to for you for you for
that, but we're going to try one more time. Really good evening.
Thank you. Welcome to our
role in a culture war and we're
going to be looking a little bit tonight at climate change and what's
our role in it? And before we do that I
would like for us to start with prayer. Can we pray together? Let's pray father.
We thank you so much for
You're gorgeous glorious.
Creation and Lord, it speaks of your glory
it speaks of your majesty and your creativity.
And so Lord. We want to be where
we belong in our understanding of what our role is.
And so give us Insight. We pray for the Holy Spirit to to
give us power and understanding as
we consider. What is our role and it's
in Jesus name we pray. Amen.
We're gonna look at four different things as it pertains
to climate change and let me
just make a disclaimer. My doctorate is in
missions and evangelism from the Seminary. So if
you want to talk about missions in evangelism, you'll be
talking to an expert at no time.
Well, here's a true story about statistics.
My master's degree is a master's degree in Christian Counseling
from Denver Seminary and I scheduled
statistics which is the closest thing
to science the very last class.
So that perhaps the diplomas would
already be printed before I took statistics just
in case.
Statistics took me out of the honors category. So so
there's what you have as far as an expert scientist
tonight, but we what we will do with great.
With great effort as look
at the biblical response. We're also going to
look at political polarization and how it affects
us and then we're going to can conclude with
kind of an exchatological view of the climate change
issue. And so the first the only word
I really want you to remember as it pertains to the biblical response is
stewardship. You'll see behind me
the definition of stewardship. It's the responsibility that
we have in maintaining and using wisely
the gifts that God has
given us.
So everything we have everything we
experience everywhere we go, no matter what climate, it's
God's he created it and
so it is our role to Steward or to
manage or to administrate what God has given us God owns
it all and we manage his gifts. And
so what we'll do first is we'll turn
to Genesis 1 now Genesis 1
anytime somebody asks you to turn there understand that
you're looking at a foundational profoundly important
piece of the entire story. You
cannot understand creation specifically,
but but you can't understand Humanity. You
can't understand creation order the role of masculinity femininity
the role of family, you can
understand anything without starting in Genesis. And
so let's just go
ahead and we'll I feel like Dr. Emerson. Remember
he says let's just start with Genesis one one.
All right, so you can look there in Genesis
1:1.
Created the heavens and the Earth.
And then he created light and separated it from Darkness.
He said let there be an expanse in
the midst of the water. So he created land he created water.
Then let the waters be full of fish and then Dryland
appeared and Sprout vegetation yielding
seeds fruits bearing fruit. See God
has been intimately involved in every aspect of creation and
the the creatures
of the sea the birds of the air the beasts the
field and then then verse 26 is where we're
going to get started.
Okay. God says let us make man in our
image and in our likeness the first issue
as it pertains to climate change
is that we need to understand
that we are a part of God's creation that it
is not us against creation it
is and and there is
where the narrative is heading is that what humanity
is doing is destroying creation. And so
we need to limit Humanity in order to save creation and
the dichotomy that that
you are being encouraged to believe is that we are we're hurting
creation. But what
we see from the very beginning harming creation that we that we
are going to undo what God has done because of
our involvement in humanity and what
you see here from the very beginning the foundational issue is that
we are part of God's creation as a matter
of fact, we're the crown crowning Glory of God's creation.
We're the master piece of God's creation when it says
let
Make man an hour image and after our likeness he
didn't do this for the fish. He didn't do this for
the birds didn't do this for the mammals didn't do this for the
vegetation. We're created in the likeness of
God and and let them have dominion over
the fish and the Sea and over the birds and the heavens and over the
livestock and over all the Earth over every creeping thing that
creeps on the earth verse 27
You can see it behind me. So God created man in his
own image in the image of God. He created him male and
female he created them. And so
there you see creation order that from the very beginning God
had a plan and what is part of God's plan verse 28
and God blessed them and said to them be
fruitful and multiply fill the
Earth and subdue it and have dominion over
the fish of the sea and over the birds, they heavens and over every living
thing that moves on the earth. And so you see from
the very beginning you don't get it earlier than Genesis one
one that God had a plan and his
plan was to include us in his creation the Masterpiece
the crown Glory of his creation so
that we could Steward it.
so that we could be intimately involved
in it, and we're going to see some some examples
of that tonight verse 15 of
chapter 2
So you're going to see another role that
God has given us here is stewards of his creation the Lord
God took the man and put him in the Garden of Eden.
To work it and to keep it.
So not only what are we a part of God's creation
and not only are we given the Mandate of
God to fill the Earth and subdue it
and to exercise Authority and dominion over it. We're put
in the garden to keep it. And by the way, I'm not
going to have you raise your hands.
How many of you didn't like your job today? Okay, sometimes
when you have a day where you don't like your job you're
thinking.
It's the curse.
You know God and because of sin we have to work. Well actually,
this is much before sin. This is this
is God saying work is a
way to worship me the way you
work.
The way you respond to the circumstances that
come at you and work as an opportunity to worship
me. And so let's just
talk a little bit about the the blessings of God's glorious
creation by rays
of hands. How many of you and I'm gonna give
you an example. I've done this before and then I teach someone for
not raising their hand or something, but I'm not gonna do that tonight.
This is just about by raise a van how many of
us have been blessed by experiencing God's
glory in creation once in their life raise your
hand. Okay. Now look around that's that's unanimous. That's unanimous. And
here's the here's a
few examples and I haven't thought of them all how
many of you have since God's glory in
a sunrise.
in a sunset
By seeing the stars are the cosmos Cosmos
is a fancy way of saying there's there's absolute evidence
that God's handiwork is on display
in the cosmos. How many of you seen God's
glory in a thunderstorm. I know that's nervous to say
that in springtime, right? I couldn't see it because I was in the
Freddy hole, right? But how many of you seen God's
glory in the mountains one of my favorite stories.
It happened to me when we lived in
Denver for almost 10 years and we lived in Golden right up
next to the Apex trail. That was the first
Trail over the Rocky Mountain and divide and
it's the trail that the Pony Express used to
get over the Continental Divide.
And so I could walk to it from my front yard. And
this day was miserable. It was cold. It's
about 45 degrees. It was wasn't completely
raining. It was kind of spitting and missing and and
I was just thinking, you know, I'm getting fat.
My wife is a good cook. I've got a good do this and
so I was running up the Apex trail and I
was most of the way I had
just another, you know, maybe a quarter of a mile before
I got to the top and then I was going to come down and gravity is a
real friend.
And so but but something began
to happen and it started to get brighter, it
was dark and Misty and and raining a
little bit and spitting and and I started to get
why and I'm thinking for myself for a minute.
I might be passing out.
I might be I felt like it right running
up the Apex Trail. I think I'm gonna pass out but it's instead of
getting darker. It's getting brighter. And what happened was as
there was real low hanging clouds and under
those clouds. It was dark and rainy and I was coming
up out of those clouds and I was able to come through the clouds
and I was able to see the glory of God in
the Brilliance of his Sunshine as it landed
on top of the the clouds and
what I just had what I knew is nobody in
Denver knew this.
I was like this is this is my gift from God today. This
is incredible and I said out. I'm
a Baptist. Okay, and I've been a Baptist for a very long time. So
I don't say things like this out loud very often, but I was like,
thank you God.
So how many?
and by the way
in the fall
Some of you are Deer Hunter and
I have no problem with that. Some
of you have been deer hunters
with the front of your sedan lately. And so we have to call that population just
to make Edmond safe. But but what I will
hear Dear Hunter say all the time is all pastor.
The forest is My Sanctuary, which means
I'm not coming to church on Sundays what that means right? So
so let's do this
for a minute. You've seen the ones that I have listed the cosmos
sunrise sunset of thunderstorm the mountains to see
and infant.
A gentle breeze a delicious meal a
powerful animal. What am I leaving off? The
list? That is a perfect explanation of God's glory
in creation. Is there anything that I missed? Say it
out loud?
rainbow bam
Say what?
Seahorses, I used
to be able to get those in the back of the comic book. Well, that's no that's
what sea monkeys weren't they anyway.
Keep coming. Keep them coming.
Roses full moon think about
this I used to do this. I taught some kids about God's
creation and I said think about berries God
didn't just make a berry. He made red berries
and strawberries and boysenberries and blackberries and
blueberries. And I said, that's the way we that's the
way God loves us is look at what he said and it's
just in berries. We're not even talking about pie and
cobbler and toppings and you know,
what else? What am I missing? What's not on my list?
Flowers say it again.
Blooming flowers were hey, we're getting there, aren't we?
Yeah, yeah.
Say it again.
ant
okay. Yeah, the the Proverbs are
full of the explanation of the ant and its strength
and why don't we work like the ant consider thou sluggered the way of
the ant I remember giving that to my son was a teenager. But anyway,
that's besides one.
Well, listen God's glorious creation.
And this this is something you might want to ride in your notes. Maybe even
the margin of your Bible in Genesis 1 God's glorious
creation, although wearing out
due to the fall.
Is still intended to bless us.
God's glory in creation
Although is wearing out due to the fall is still intended
to bless us. Let's look now at the
fall and the emergence of sin and its effect
on God's creation. This is Genesis 3:17. So
and to Adam he said because you've listened to the voice of your wife.
We're taking that one out of context fellas. I'm gonna rest there
feel pretty good about it. Okay. All right. The context
is he was standing right there doing nothing is passive as
he's ever been and it was his fault. Okay, but because
he listens to his wife and have eaten of the tree which I
commanded you you shall not eat of it cursed is
the ground because of you.
In pain, you shall eat of it
all the days of your life.
Thorin and thistles it shall bring forth for you.
You shall eat the plants of the field and by
the sweat of your face you shall eat bread till you
return to the ground for you were taken out of it for you
are dust and to dust you shall return so
God glorious creation,
it speaks of his magnificence. It speaks
of his Splendor his Brilliance. It's creativity. But
as a result of sin now we see that God's
glorious creation will wear out and
it is in danger in ways that had
never been in danger before sin. But now
what we have is the curse of the ground and
the pain that it causes and that's what makes
work hard. And how many
of you have sprayed pre-emergent on your lawns.
All right, why because the weeds
are coming.
And you have to stay ahead of them. You don't have
you have to sew the grass seed and you have to water the
grass and fertilize the grass. You can't hardly stop the weeds
here. They come right thorns and thistles
are reality, but they're
also metaphorical for the
things in our life that bring us pain.
And the things in our life that make that make life difficult and I
used to I used to laugh.
This is just how silly you are when you're young. I used
to laugh at certain hymns and nobody knows
the trouble. I've seen nobody knows
but Jesus and there's another one that because he
lives.
I Can Face Tomorrow I used to think those are
just so sad and now
I sing them every day, right because you live long enough
you begin to understand the thorns and thistles and the pain that
comes as you live in the curse
and in the Brokenness of the world today and by
the sweat of your face.
But but what I want you to see is that even after
the fall there is this intrinsic.
Fundamental Link in between
Humanity the crown crowning
Glory of God's creation and creation look
at job. Okay job 12.
It's behind me here verse 7
job, you know his story he was
a it was a God-fearing man and probably the
scariest verse and all of the Bible as you've considered
my servant job. And so Satan begins
to test job and he loses everything and then he
gets sick with sores and he's lost his
wife his kids his wealth and his health. And so
now he's got friends coming by saying, you know,
I think it's some sort of unconfessed sin in your
life. And so they're coming up with reasons why God would allow this to happen
and listen to what job says. No, no.
No, he says ask the Beast and they
will teach you the birds of the heavens and they
will tell you or the bushes of the earth and they will teach
you the fish of the sea will.
There to you who among all these do not
know the hand of the Lord has done this.
In his hand the life of everything of every
living thing and the breath of all mankind.
So God in his sovereignty is in
control and he is included us as stewards of
all that he has done.
Earlier, I was talking about this
verse right here Psalms 24:1 speaking
of worship.
The Earth is the Lord's and the fullest fullness
thereof and the war and the world and those who
dwell therein. See there's this in
An absolutely fundamental link of between
the creation and the crowning Glory of
creation. The Masterpiece creation Humanity Psalms 96:11,
let the heavens be glad and
let the Earth rejoice and let the sea Roar
and all that fills it let the field exalt and
everything in it.
Then shall all the trees in the forests sing
for joy.
So you see the very Heart Of God expressed in
the song Psalms and
poetry of God expressing that even the
rocks will cry out.
There is this link.
And then we get to the New Testament. All right.
So the Paul is
riding to colossi and he's this is a doxology if
you will explaining who is this Jesus? He is
the image of the invisible God the firstborn
of what?
of all creation
for by him all things were created in heaven and on Earth
visible and invisible whether Thrones or dominions
or rulers or authorities.
All things were created through him and for
him.
And he is before all things and in him all
things hold together. So we're beginning
to get a better christology of God's
creation and Christ's involvement in
it. He's holding it together. It was
created through him and it was created for him including
us and our involvement in it. And then
lastly Revelation 4:11.
Worthy OU our Lord and God, by the way, this is the
epitome of the best example of
worship. You could possibly get these are the 24
Elders who are falling on their face
and now given God's
Divine empowerment are able to express exactly.
Who is this Jesus worthy. Are you
our Lord and God to receive glory and honor and
power for you created all things and
by your will they existed and we're
created.
So what are we to do with this?
Where are we to stand on
this vast array of opportunities in
this climate change chaos. All
right. Well, I
I went to John Piper. I I don't use
John Piper as an example very often because I think he's
so lofty when I say it sounds Hollow, right? But
he came up with a great metaphor for how we
treat the gods creation
how we view it and perceive it
and he used the Earth and
he used the paraphraser that not the paraphrase
but the metaphor the image or the symbol symbol of
our bodies.
Our bodies like the Earth.
Are wearing out. All right. And by
the way, if you don't know that if you're too young to know that enjoy that
enjoy that when you
get to a certain age, and I am that age if it falls
on the floor you consider its value because it might just have to stay there.
I might just walk on say somebody else younger than me might want to pick
that up because I'm not doing it right I try
to stay healthy.
And how do you do that? Well, you
have to stay after it. You have to exercise regularly.
As God's stewards we should treat the Earth
as we treat our physical bodies. Our bodies are wearing
out. We should intentionally in stab it establish
healthy habits. Here's a
few of them. I think you should be intentional about playing and
having fun. My wife lets me
go play Pickleball. She doesn't play and
so when I'm gone I'm away from her, but she thinks she
thinks it's great. Why because she sees how decrepit I'm
becoming anything we can do to get this guy
to play right and then exercise.
I think it's gonna get warmer here
soon. We've been checking the weather to see if we can walk in the
mornings Caroline. I love to walk every morning why we
don't we don't keep our time.
We don't there's not a race that we're planning on
running some of you do good for you.
I'm built for stability and high winds not so
much gazelle-like. But but I think
exercising is good. I think weight training, you know,
you think about weight training. How do you lift more weights?
By lifting more weights and if you want to get stronger, you
have to lift harder you have to lift more and so
it's it's a struggle right but it but but
whether you're playing or
exercising or resting or
sleeping, you're working at building strength, you're
stretching. This is the thing I hate the
most is stretching.
My wife laughs at me because I
make noises when I stretch.
It's not fair. She just reaches over and touches her toes.
I reach over it's like mmm. She thinks
hilarious, right? But why are we doing this? Well,
we're working at trying to make our
body work the way God designed it to work.
But as a result of us growing older as a result
of the Fall as a result of our propensity for
not working out for not playing
for not sleeping for not eating. Well things get
hard even more difficult. So we limit
unhealthy Foods. We eat healthy foods.
We worship God by caring for our
bodies and by caring for God's glorious creation.
So this is the metaphor that I
think we can use in our efforts to know. What is
the right thing to do as it pertains to God's
glorious creation. We're going to
talk a minute about political polarization and while that why
that is a threat, but right now I just want us to rest for
a moment in thinking
How do I worship God in my involvement in
creation?
You're going to have an opportunity guys. I'm new to
Edmond. I was from Tulsa both.
My kids went to UCO so Edmund to me
and forgive me for not knowing any better and to
me was I 44 I-35 North
Second Avenue.
when I went home, it was Second Avenue, I-35 South
I-44 so I thought to myself
Edmonds not that pretty
but since then we moved to Edmond and
we looked at the city and we bought a home and now I
drive down sorghum Mill
and it is glorious. We got here in
June. It was a the peak of the summer green and and
we had a long green summer and
then the trees just turned glorious and for
several weeks. I'd like to say months, but
I think it was probably just weeks we had all different kinds of
fall colors and Carolyn we're just saying this place is
gorgeous.
Now it went dormant.
Yeah, and so for a several weeks, I've
been looking at dead grass and dead trees. But guess
what if you look down where the Tulips are
and where the daffodils are they're about two inches out and it's always
a sign saying yes, but Easter's coming right and
before long some of you're gonna be saying yeah, I'm
gonna have hey favor and I got to have my Claritin sure that's
true, but it's going to be glorious again. And and
that's by Design. That's God's gift
to us. And so how do we take care
of it? So I'm going to tell you something to the young people in
the crowd, okay?
You're not going to believe this but people used to
just throw their trash out their window.
They didn't in an effort to try to keep their car clean. They would just throw their trash
out the window. Let's do this. Okay, because
no one does this now.
Right if you do shame on you, but how many
of you remember when you were a child see in
your parents just throw things out the window to keep the car clean. See
look. This wasn't that long ago, right?
We're doing so much better. Right? But
anyway, I think there are
things that we can do to take care of God as
stewards to take care of God's glorious creation
and in doing so we are in entering
into intentionally that Divine Link in between
being between God's creation and
God's Crown Glory of creation his Masterpiece
that being Humanity. Okay, we're not separate from
creation. We're a part of creation and and we
worship God by by being
involved in sustaining God's beautiful creation.
amen
Okay, now we'll talk about the fun stuff.
Okay, we're gonna talk about a political polarization. Okay,
the nature of American politics
these days is to divide and
polarize to divide and polarize
I remember growing
up there were three channels and there were three news stations and
they they had news
programs at five and 10 pm.
Okay, and like Dana
Carvey used to say in Saturday Night Live that's the way it was
and we liked it right, but but now
we have lots of news channels and in
order to try to gain an audience
They have learned to appeal to a certain
political polarized position
whether that's on the right or the left
and not to teach not to to share
news but to tease with news so that
you'll watch the commercial and come back and hear what the
story is about. And so it's it's very little news. But as a
result, then we have this wide variety of extremes and
it's not just about us climate change.
It's about all the issues that we've talked about
religious freedom lgbtq issues
race relations as well as climate
change and so it is wise to
avoid the extremes and I've listed these
extremes for you. Okay, you will hear
politically polarized charges from
left-leaning political
figures that Doom is coming.
In fact, it's probably too late.
And they'll even give you dates within 20 years.
And unless we you know vote for me or vote for my party.
We're in trouble. Okay, so some would
say that we're it's you know, it's too late that
we've we've we've extinguished Humanity as
we know it right just to the right of that as
they will believe it's it's too late. There's nothing
we can do and we have to do everything we can just to
preserve life for a few more decades. Okay, and now
just to the right of that we see
a human solution and we can fix this.
All right, we can fix this if we do the right
things and then they've got a list of things that they
think we should do in order to fix this and then
to the right of that is a we
deny human solution. There's
nothing that we can do it's going
to do what it's going to do. It's always done what it's always done
and there's nothing we can do to fix it. There's nothing we can do to change
it. We're definitely we can do to help there's nothing we can do to hurt
it is what it is. It always has been that way. All right, and that
same crowd will deny human causation.
Saying that there's nothing that Humanity
does that changes the course of nature.
We know that on a micro level that's
not true.
That without certain parameters that
we will in fact pollute the
environment so we have certain governing laws
along the
way like right now if they say you throw something out of your
car you get a ticket for it and I think that's the right
thing.
So you have to agree that along the
way there are things that we can do that can
improve the the
climate as we know it.
You guys remember aerosol cans?
And now there's still out
there, but they're harder to find and people are would much
and they've gotten better at the pump action stuff. You guys
remember freon?
free animals that
everybody used in their car to keep their car cold and then when
they realize that Freon was real hard on the ozone, so
they've have a new mixture of chemicals that keep your
car cold and so things happen along the way
that I think are not bad things to do but what
I'm saying is is that
Some deny that humans have anything to do with the climate changing.
Okay, some deny
that climate change exists at all.
That this is just another part of a random pattern
in history. Sometimes it gets hotter. Sometimes it
gets cooler. And then lastly some
see climate change is an opportunity to decease control
that the government will take over in order
to try to save the planet. And so what I'm
asking you to do is consider wisdom and work
at trying to avoid the extremes. Where do
we land on this pastor Phil? Well,
It kind of depends where you stand politically and and
I'm not here to tell you where to how to vote.
I'm here to tell you that we are stewards of God's creation and
that there is an intrinsic Link in between his
creation and us and so we're responsible as stewards
for maintaining what God has created. But one
thing that we're learning in a survey of
over 10,000 people Pew research survey has
has learned this and that is the main
driver.
Of public opinion about climate change
is is not religion.
it's
your political party
and Republicans are far less likely
than Democrats to believe that human activity is causing
global warming.
Or to consider climate change as a serious problem. That's that's the
way Republicans believe the same
is true for the religious Republicans among
them religious people who identify and lean Republican are
less inclined to be concerned about global warming than the
people of the same religion who identify and lean towards the Democratic party.
It's just it's statistics on a
10,000 person survey, but but
clearly evangelicals have a reputation
for denying the dangers of climate change, for example
34% of evangelicals say climate
change is an extremely or very serious
problem just 34% of evangelicals.
But if you break the evangelicals down
by political party, you see a more polarizing picture
emerging now you're beginning to see why this
has become such a problem because we have Polar Opposites
saying opposite things and agreeing with a
political platform.
Listen to this 78% of
evangelicals who lean towards the Democratic party
say that climate change is an extremely or
various serious problem.
78% whereas 17% of
evangelicals who lean Republicans say climate
change is an extremely are very serious problem. So it's
it's not a religious issue as much as it is
a political issue and it's a political issue because the the
American system works at polarizing you in order
to get you to change your vote and devote your direction and other direction.
So this survey also found that climate change is not
a topic discussed much in religious congregations.
And I don't think that's an accident.
If it is an issue that is polarizing then let's
not talk about it. Right and so
I wanted to put this on here 8% say they've heard a
great deal about climate change and sermons eight percent.
Seventy percent say they hear little or nothing about climate
change turn to the person next to
you say congratulations. You're in a pretty you're in the top 30% of the churches.
All right. All right. So now about
half the Americans want to
take steps to protect the environment.
Like reducing food waste or using fewer
Plastics or driving less or
eating less meat. I thought this was funny. So I included it
in the slide behind me here to evangelicals scored
lowest on these efforts, especially
eating less meat
so congratulations the potluck pulls through
amen. Alright the casserole. All right. So now
we're going to switch from that Pew research
to LifeWay research and I've skirted
a little bit of controversy by
poking at the pastors LifeWay likes
to interview pastors because a it these
are influence makers
in congregations across the landscape, but
B, we will they'll answer your call and you
do a survey
so they found that 53% of
protestant pastors agree with this statement.
I believe global warming is real and
man-made.
That also includes 34% who say I strongly agree
that global warming is real and man-made.
Okay. So 38%
believe global warming
is real and man disagree. The global
warming is real and man-made and 24% strongly
disagree that global warming is
real and man-made and then 10% and and I I frankly I
may be in the 10%
Okay, I believe in some of
the statistics that I read, but I also know that a lot of the statistics are
politically motivated and therefore polarizing by
by.
But by the way, we are in America today,
but 10% say they're not sure whether they
believe global warming is real or man-made.
So we're going to show next this LifeWay
research is going to show next that it's it's politically
motivated and not necessarily
religiously motivated. Look at this.
Look at this graph behind me. Do you believe global warming
is real and man-made you can see that in 2008. It
was almost 50/50 split.
the some agreed that it was and some disagreed it was
not
But then you can see just over two years that it
began to grow in popularity that it was not real to
the point of 60% disagreed not real.
It's not man-made. It's not even a thing. Whereas 36
believed that it did and then since 2010 we've
seen a complete change in
what pastors believe about global warming
2002 is it was coming down
54 and 43 percent and
then now in 2019, we see 53% of
pastors agreed that global warming is
real and man-made where is only 38% do not
believe that it is real. So there's pastors are
still split on the subject. But even
more telling in this research is
the is the reality of the political divide among
pastors and I'm just going to show you a few of those changes a
few of these how the the survey emerged
some data that we were not expecting concerning demographics
and and denominational.
Lines, okay, 78% of African-American
pastors are most likely to agree
that global warming is real and man-made 59% of
the youngest pastors. That's pastors
ages 18 through 44 are more
likely to agree in 47% of pastors
that are 65 years of age and older are more
likely to agree.
so you can see there the trend is that it's it's
a politically motivated decision and it's
also an age-related decision
now look at as it pertains
to
as it pertains to education a 59% of
pastors with a doctoral degree are more likely to agree. The
global warming is real and man-made whereas 58%
of pastors with a master's degree.
However, 43% of pastors with a bachelor's
degree are more likely to agree and then only 35% of
pastors with no college degree are likely
to agree that it's real so you can begin to
see that there's a there's a trend and the trend follows political
motivations not necessarily religious motivations. Finally
as it pertains to different denominations 80% of
pastors from Methodist. Churches are more likely to agree
67% of pastors from presbyterian
or reformed churches or more likely to agree that it's
real a man-made 63 from Lutheran churches and
37% of pastors from Baptist. Churches are
a lot more likely to agree.
I'm trying not to say this. Hey, let's hear for
the Baptists. Okay, whereas 32% of
pastors from Pentecostal churches are more likely to
agree. So again, you see that it's not
as it's not as religiously motivated as it
is politically motivated.
And so what do we do with this data?
You're saying I just came to find out what I should believe.
And what I've told you is that you are inextricably linked
to God's creation that God's creation expresses
God's glory and you get to be a part of it as
God's Steward and that is that's his
plane as as any theology in scripture to
me. All right. So what do we do? Well, we rest
in God's sovereignty.
And in God's future promises, what does that
mean?
Well, that means that God is in control.
And we should do the very best we can.
With the statutes and
precepts he has given us.
to obey
for his glory
We also understand that there are things that
are outside of our control that are not our job that we
can rest in God's sovereignty that he's going to take care of this. Okay
assalms 102 25 and
26.
Of old you laid the foundation of
the earth and the heavens are the work of your hands. They
will perish.
But you will remain they will all wear out like a
garment.
You will change them like a robe and they will pass
away.
Though God knows when this you know, just like
our body is going to wear out and is wearing out
even as we speak a minute. We'll have an intermission and I'm
gonna ask you to stand you're going to get up gonna groan like, oh, how
long was that?
All right, but
but the Earth is is wearing out as well as a
result of the Fall.
Okay, but we can we can trust that God is
God is in control because he is Isaiah
51:6 lift up your eyes to the heavens and
look to the Earth beneath for the heaven the
heavens will vanish like smoke and the
Earth will wear out like a garment and they who dwell in
it will die and like manner but my salvation will be
forever. Can I get an amen and my righteousness
will never be dismayed. Amen. God can
be trusted in his sovereignty is secure and
for me to take up arms and
for me to to disfellowship and
for me to worry and anxiety and to call
names and to not be able to sleep and to on and
on the things that we do
that's forgetting that God is Sovereign, isn't it hot?
If I if I if I can't trust God to be
who God says he is and if I
cannot remember the future promises that he has made then
am I not kind of replacing him with
my own set of values.
I think so.
Now we skip to the New Testament.
In fact, I'd like to
I've only listed for you versus 10 through 12, but
let's look at second Peter 3.
Second Peter 3:15 is the verse that I'm going
to ask us to land on for a minute, but but I
want us to look.
at verse 8
Okay for every Bible is good and turn.
there
this is basically talking about suffering for for righteousness
sake the early church as it
began to turn to God begin to experience
suffering as a result of political pressures the
first 450 years of church history
The Church was against the law.
And you could die as a result. As a matter of fact, the catacombs
are Stacks and stacks of Christian Martyrs who
were died in and buried in Mass Graves.
So it was not an easy time to be a Christian at
all. But listen what Peter says finally Brothers
all of you have Unity of Mind sympathy
brotherly love a tender heart
and a humble mind. This doesn't sound like a fight.
does it
This doesn't sound like get ready. Bring it
on. Let's go to war.
What does it sound like?
Verse 9 don't repay evil for evil or reviling
for reviling but on the
contrary bless.
For to this you were called the you
may obtain a blessing bless.
For to this you were called to obtain a blessing.
Forever to desires to love life and see good
days. Let him keep his tongue from evil and his lips from speaking to
seat. Let him turn away from Evil and do good.
Let him seek peace and pursue it for the eyes of
the Lord or on the righteousness and his ears are open to their prayers,
but the face of the Lord is against those who do
evil.
So even though we talk about being in a culture War
this the early church was in a war for
its very existence. It was against the law.
Now now we're in the first Peter 3:13.
Now who is there to harm you if you are zealous for
what is good for you? Even if you should suffer for
righteousness sake you will be blessed have no fear
of them nor be troubled but in your hearts, this is
verse 15, and this is a what I
would recommend that you do as it pertains
to
My response for people who disagree with
me. Okay, first Peter, what did I say?
A weird second Peter. We'll be in second Peter in a minute.
first Peter 3:15
Yes, sir. I got first and second Peter messed up there.
Look at this but in your hearts.
Honor Christ Lord as holy.
Always being prepared to make a defense to anyone who
asks you for the for a reason for the
hope that is in you yet. Do it with gentleness and respect.
so
the word give a
defense or give an answer is in the
Greek is called a polygia. It's where we get our word
apologetics. Okay. It's being
prepared to answer people for
the hope that is in you. Let me
give you a
Kind of a scenario that that you probably familiar
with.
in the current political
culture
people are more willing to repost a cleverly
worded.
retort
than they are to be gentle and respectful and I
think sometimes well, you
heard Brother Bruce Ashford saying
that his his uncle he didn't know how to
use his keyboard because they took the all caps key off right?
I think
we as Christians.
Need to be very very careful when it comes to giving
a defense because defensiveness in
our culture. Sometimes me means rising
to the level of offense. Like
if someone comes hard at you with what
they believe about lgbtq or
race relations issues or religious freedom
or climate change if they come hard at you it's easiest
for you to rise up and come back just as hard.
But what have we just read?
that
that it's better to suffer for righteousness and doing good
than to win an argument. You might win the
argument lose the battle.
Right that that after the
manner of Christ the hope that we have is not
in.
In fighting our way to the top the hope.
Is that our Our Savior laid down his life.
And took our scars.
And so as a result, then that's that's the hope that we
have.
In your hearts verse 15 honor Christ
as Lord as holy.
Always being prepared to make a defense to anyone who asks you for a
reason for the hope that is in you.
Here's the two. Here's the two questions as we draw too. Close
Okay question number one.
Do you have that hope in you?
Do you have a resounding sense of
hope?
As our pastors preached through Titus and
and as he's preached through how to
how to behave and how to act and how to be involved
and doing good. When you
do good you begin to experience the reality
of the fact that God has given us this hope and this
hope is spilling out of us.
And do you have that hope is that
hope spilling out and is it not spilling out because you
have forgotten God's sovereignty and
assumed his role as the one who needs to
change the outcome.
Okay.
Now we're going to scoot to Second Peter.
Talking about God's sovereignty and future promises.
second Peter 3:10
But the day of the Lord will come like a thief.
And then the heavens will pass away with a Roar and the heavenly bodies
will be burned up and dissolved and the
earth and the works that are done on it will be exposed since
all these things are thus to be dissolved what
sort of people ought you live, are you to
live lives of Holiness and godliness?
Waiting for and hastening for the coming of the day of God because
of the heavens which will be set on fire and dissolved and
the Earthly bodies. They will melt as they burn.
Jesus
said in both Matthew 24 and Mark 13
Heaven and Earth will pass away but my words will
not pass away.
So and then here's the final promise
of God and and frankly, I
can't tell you exactly how this is going to happen or when this is going to
happen. But because it's the promise of God, I know that it is going to happen the
Revelation 21:1. I saw a new Heaven and
a new Earth.
For the first Heaven and the first Earth had passed away and the
sea was no more.
So God has a plan and that plan is Ultimate Redemption
and Perfection and and I thought
about this later. It's not a part of my notes. But remember earlier when
we talked about the metaphor of the body and the Earth that just
like the Earth the body is wearing out and just
like the Earth the body can't do it at once did and
just like the Earth of the body is sore and ways
that it's never been sore before just like the Earth.
One day I'll get a brand new body.
and
makes me emotional to talk about this because I've not really told you
guys about my brother. I lived I grew up in a family of four
and my older brother was five and a half years older than me. He was the
epitome of physical Perfection back before
the days of political correctness. He was voted best looking
sophomore Junior and Senior year.
That was my big brother. Okay, and
here comes the freckled face little brother and I
was so thankful that they took that category away. I was
like, you know, I would have wanted to Paul but that didn't give it out when I was there,
you know, which is not true. But he he got a yes
of a scholarship to play football at Missouri Southern University
was a part of the NIH NAIA division two
national champions, and I wanted to be just like him.
But as I started dating my wife she used
to say to me. Why is Paul always so tired?
And we didn't know it but that was the beginning of multiple sclerosis.
And Paul battled multiple the multiple sclerosis for
about 38 years the last 16 years.
He lived at home with my mom.
And had to have full-time care
as he got to where he could not transfer from the bed to
the chair and the chair to the restroom and back and forth.
And so there were times when Paul's old body
was just not able to do anything like a
body should and that was my big brother the guy that I kind of
idolized growing up that I want to be just like
and so when I read about one day that God will give us a new Heaven
and a new Earth and a new body. I think
of my brother running the way he used to
run.
And dancing the way he used to dance and leaping
and clapping and laughing the way
he used to leave and clap and laugh and see just like our
bodies one day. We'll be restored because of God's glory.
because of God's Redemptive power
Earth will be returned that way too. Think about
it.
Those glorious trees on sorghum mail.
Those are the broken sin infected
trees and one day
when sin is no more and God is reclaimed
and redeemed it all they're going to be with the way he designed them
and won't they be even more glorious? Amen?
So I want to do next.
is
don't leave. I mean you can if you want to it's free
country y'all but
We're gonna give you an intermission. It's going to be about a three or four
minute information. I want you to stand up and turn around and and if
you know the person next you really well scratch them
on the back or something, you know, massage their shoulders.
Okay, everybody stand up one two, three go. This is
an intermission.
We're coming back for the final warning.
Testing one two, all right.
Don't recommend a pastor John he give
you an intermission on Sundays.
He doesn't get to go for an hour and 15 minutes. So what I
wanted to do since this is our last Wednesday night
together.
What next week is spring break and
then the following week after that? We'll start disciple making
201 really excited about that. But this is
the close of our four-week study on Hot Topics
in the climate. I mean in the
culture wars, I wanted to give you guys some hope
concerning this question. How do Disciples of
Jesus Christ have a productive conversation with
people who disagree no matter
what the topic is, they disagree with you. They don't believe there's
a new morality sweeping through it's coming
through with great complexity and great velocity and
you're going to be on the wrong side of History if you don't agree. So
how do we have a productive conversation? Well,
it's the verse we just read
Set Jesus Christ apart in your heart says Lord
as holy always being prepared to
make a defense for the hope that's inside of you, but do it with
gentleness and respect. I wanted
to to give you four things to do. First of all,
leave God's work.
to God
All right, you guys if this summer
Heath will be here Dr. Heath will
be here and he's going to preach to Joel and Joel 2:28 through
32 talks about him an outpouring of the holy
spirit in the last days and and then
you can leap forward into the
New Testament. You can read in Acts to when Peter's addressing
the crowd after the coming of the Holy Spirit and
he quotes from Joel about the explaining the
coming of the Holy Spirit and these people are not
drunk as you may have suggested but these people are full of
the spirit because the prophet Joel said that there would be in that outpouring of
the holy spirit in power. So if God promised
power and gave us the Holy Spirit then why
would we want to do God's work for him?
All right. Now we have
to admit that sometimes we meddle in God's work.
Whenever I worry.
I forget that this is God's work.
All right.
When you're when you're my age and you're you're hired by a church
to be the pastor of discipleship and community in a
church, who says they want to become an all ages hub for
a disciple making movement. If you're
not careful, you can set up late at night and wonder how are
we going to do this?
And then I remember oh, wait a minute. This is
God's work.
And God does what God wants to do. I don't have to worry. I
don't worry about when Jesus will return. I don't
have to worry about other things too. I don't have to worry about
changing people's lives. That's it's God's responsibility
and through their own obedience and Faith. We're only
responsible for ourselves before God.
We're not responsible for others. We're not responsible for
even our own family members and friends. We don't
have to worry about the problems of our health beyond our
control.
God's that's God's job.
We don't have to worry about our finances. We we Steward
God's gifts.
But we can pray about those things and we can entrust
him with those things. So why don't we just leave God's work
to God?
Okay and been that
long ago, but I woke up one day and realized that God is God and
I am not.
How about you?
And number two you can do
your part with God's power remember in
Joel and in Acts God's Mission begins
with God's power.
And we don't have to do anything to earn God's power.
We just receive it because God promised it to us.
Okay, we discover in the moment that we entrust our
life to Christ. We first asked for forgiveness of
our sins. And God gives us the Holy Spirit to come in and
to take charge of our lives and then God puts his
holy spirit within us.
The rhetorical question that Paul asked is don't you know that you
are the Temple of the Holy Spirit and spirit of
God dwells in you.
Now because I had to study
this stuff in seminary Holy Spirit
begins with power and in the Greek that word is dunamis
and it's where we get our word dynamite and
you guys remember Jenny Jimmy Walker.
Don oh my
Right. That's the same word and that's
the and it's it's not a mistake.
Think about this especially as it pertains to climate
change. Okay, you don't have to become
an academically Elite scholar or scientists to
win an argument.
Nor do we have to be a great Theologian to
impact the hidden meanings of the revelation. We
just have to be able to say well this is what God's done
in my life.
And this is how my life is different because of Jesus and no
one can argue your own personal witness because
it's your individual experience. It's your
story and you don't have to share it.
If you don't share it, it's not going to be shared.
So I want to talk a
little bit about gentleness and respect. Okay, number three
reflect Jesus gentleness.
And his respectful way.
So when we when we studied about the
lgbtq agenda I didn't I didn't
have an opportunity to share with you my experience with my niece. I
told you about my brother with his multiple sclerosis when my
niece was probably 10.
Their marriage began to dissolve because
of his Ms. He could no longer work.
and
they had a beautiful home. He was a home builder helped me and Carol
build our first home and but he couldn't do that anymore. And so the
church came alongside them and started paying their
bills because that's what the church does but
He was also harder to get out of the house, you know harder to
get dressed on Sunday morning harder to get out of the house. So they're
attendance begin to wane Wax and Wane
and and as their attendance begin to wax and
Wayne their support began to slow down as often
happens.
And so she had to go back to work in order to make money for them
to make bills me and while she was back to work. She met someone.
And so as a result of my brother's sickness as
a result of they're not being involved in church as a
result of her.
Of her dad and having to go live with her grandparents.
My little niece began to
experience not just frustration, but
sexual confusion.
And that she was raised playing soccer and
she had a division one college scholarship to Missouri
University. And so while she was at Missouri University,
she was a she was exposed to same sex
attraction. She followed through with that exposure and
we begin to see it happening.
She would bring friends home and she never came out as
someone who identified herself as
a lesbian, but she was living the lesbian lifestyle and on
the college campus and we had heard rumors and we
saw it happening.
And I want to have to tell you a conversation that I
had with my mother and this is why I'm telling the story, okay?
So my brother had moved
in with my parents in June.
And I yes and then
July one month later. My dad died of a heart attack.
Okay. So while that sounds like a sad story
my mom never had to be alone.
And now my brother had full-time.
Full-time care, so it was a kind of a perfect solution.
That God had kind of put together for them.
but
my my mom came to me and she said Phil.
Do you think Sarah?
Is she didn't even know how to say it.
you know, do you think Sarah's like
like other girls
and I said yeah Mom I do.
And when my mom gets really serious her voice
goes low and she talks like she doesn't
talk and she said feel.
We're just going to love her.
Okay.
And you know, I mean, I'm I'm my brother's only
brother and I I wanted to defend him because he kind
of been Dishonored and disrespected by his wife and and I
wanted to be able to Champion my cause you know, and I was
a professional speaker. I think I could have probably lamb but lambastian's as
good as anybody but you know what we did.
We just loved her.
And she in The Catcher from the softball team moved off
to Chicago together when they graduated and we're like, oh
no.
What's going to happen?
And then they broke up.
and my little niece was
lonely for the first time in her life.
And so she was raised in the church, even though she
hadn't been the last 10 or 15 years. She decided she
was going to go to church.
And she she went to a gay friendly
Church in Chicago and she didn't feel the Holy
Spirit and she went to a second gay friendly Church in Chicago. She didn't
feel the Holy Spirit and on our way home. I just want you to want you
to see when God is at work doing what God
does best.
He doesn't need our help.
And so she could not find a place to attend
church where she sensed the presence of the Holy Spirit and so
she's a half a mile from her apartment at First
Baptist Church Downers Grove and she
stops by to find out what time the service starts.
And a little Baptist Deacon
with gray hair and coat and tie is a greeter.
They stand out the parking lot and he sees my little niece get
out. She's got her skin tight leather pants and her spiky hair.
And and he takes off across the parking
lot.
And and she says oh hi. Just
want to find out what time your services are and he grabs
her and he hugs her.
And she says to me later Phil. That was the first time I'd been touched by
anybody in two weeks and I felt home.
She said I just want to find out what time the services are and
because he's a man who can pretend to be deaf.
He says hurry, we're gonna be late and he grabs
her by the hand and he starts dragging her towards the
auditorium and she knows I mean, she was raised in church. She knows
what time the services she knows. It's going to be there in the middle of the service.
He takes her down the middle aisle and sets her right next to
the pastor's wife during the sermon.
He's just dragging her. You know, I can't I
can see it in my mind. It was just it had to be a comedy and while
he's while she is sitting next to the pastor's
wife. The pastor's wife writes her note says can you eat lunch
with us today?
And she finds herself sitting in the pastors house.
On the very day. She just stopped by to find out what time the
services were.
And she ate lunch with a pastor and his wife the next three Sundays in
a row.
And on the third Sunday the Pastor said, so when did you meet Christopher?
And she goes who's Christopher?
And so, you know Christopher Yuan was
a flamboyantly gay man who was gloriously
saved and then sent to prison
had HIV and miraculously delivered while
in prison he comes to know Christ and he decides
instead of being a flamboyant gay
man. He's going to be a minister.
I don't know anybody that will
give me an endorsement to go to Wheaton Bible College.
But he gets in Wheaton Bible College.
and his mom and dad
were saved through his testimony and they go to First Baptist
Church Downers Grove.
Somehow when Sarah moved
to Chicago she moved a
block away from maybe the only gay friendly Southern Baptist Church
in the entire United States of America.
What a coincidence.
or not
maybe we let God do God's work.
Maybe we reflect Jesus gentle and respectful way.
And maybe we just wait for jesus' return let him fix
this thing. Jesus disciples watch their lord
enter into the clouds.
He had shown up for almost about a month about 25 days.
And then he has sins into the clouds. And those clouds are
symbolic for God's Shekinah Glory. You
remember in the Old Testament? The clouds always symbolize
God's presence and Moses when he
was with the Israelite people in the desert, they followed
the pillar of cloud in the Tabernacle. And
when the temple or when God revealed his
glory there was this Shekinah Glory of God. Well now Jesus on
the Mount of transfiguration with his micro group
Peter James and John and now he's
ascending into the clouds and when he
gets just out of side into the clouds what the
Angels say
All right.
You've been looking long enough. It's time to get to work.
And so sometimes we enjoy the Warm Glow of God's presence.
And sometimes we were slow to follow God's
Direction, but here just like these angels reassured
the disciples. Jesus will return
Church Jesus is coming again.
And we can look to the skies. Our job
is to be ready.
Our job is to serve him the way he's called us today in
and day out knowing that even today could be our very last day.
So let's make it a great day.
Let's watch for him. The way the Holy Spirit
wants to use us with that Dynamite power.
Let's watch for God's purposes to unfold around
us things that only God can do beyond our
control and then when we're ready whenever it's time.
He'll come again.
Let's pray.